Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club Islam, is the city of well-being. In it is to be found the learning which all the world desires to possess, and elegance and perfect courtesy. Its science is as penetrating as its winds are balmy. In it is to be found the best of everything that the world can boast and all things that are beautiful.
感谢您收听《历史的余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。伊斯兰，是幸福之城。世人渴望拥有的学识、优雅与完美的礼仪，皆汇聚于此。其科学如其微风般沁人心脾。世间所能夸耀的一切美好事物，皆在此处。
From it comes everything that is worth knowing and everyone with any claim to fashion is drawn to it. It is the city of people's hearts. And Tom Holland, the podcaster of People's Hearts, you are back for the fourth time in this mighty series on the history of Baghdad and the Islamic Golden Age. And today I'm very excited because we will be talking about Aladdin, Sinbad, and the Arabian Nights, won't we, Tom? We will. Flying carpets, genies, all the works, but not first, Dominic. Oh, that's disappointing. You're going to make me wait.
一切值得知晓的事物皆源于此，任何追求时尚的人都会被它吸引。它是人们心中的城市。汤姆·霍兰德，这位“人心”播客的主播，欢迎你第四次回到这个关于巴格达历史和伊斯兰黄金时代的宏大系列节目中。今天我非常兴奋，因为我们要谈论阿拉丁、辛巴达和《一千零一夜》，对吧，汤姆？没错。飞毯、精灵，应有尽有，但多米尼克，不是现在。哦，真令人失望。你竟然要让我等。
No, because we've got loads of other exciting things to talk about as well. Just on the Arabian Nights, the Arabian Nights have become, for a lot of people, so Theo, our producer, said he has only a very vague knowledge of the Arabian Nights. He knows there's carpets and there's lamps and genies. There's the Disney film, isn't there? Aladdin. Yes. So I'm sure lots of children see that.
不，因为我们还有很多其他令人兴奋的事情要谈。就拿《一千零一夜》来说，对很多人来说，《一千零一夜》已经变得……我们的制作人西奥说他对《一千零一夜》只有非常模糊的了解。他知道里面有地毯、神灯和精灵。还有迪士尼电影，对吧？《阿拉丁》。是的。所以我相信很多孩子都看过。
And in Britain, children go to pantomimes and you'll still get Aladdin and things like that. Oh, absolutely, you will. People still talk about my appearance in Sinbad the Sailor at the Theatre on the Steps in Bridge North in the early 1980s. Who did you play in uh in that so there was a character who gets shrunk like an old man who gets shrunk and i played him
在英国，孩子们会去看童话剧，你依然能看到《阿拉丁》之类的剧目。哦，当然会。人们至今还在谈论我 20 世纪 80 年代初在布里奇诺斯“台阶剧院”出演《辛巴达航海记》的经历。你在那部剧里演了谁？有一个角色会被缩小，像个被缩小的老头，我演的就是他。
once he'd been shrunk as a sort of capering child but i was painted green i was totally green tom you didn't play the terrifying old man who um sinbad meets him and he asks for a lift because my legs are frail. I cannot walk. And so Sinbad, being a very nice guy, lifts him up and the man kind of clasps him, wraps his legs around him and Sinbad can't get him off. I could have been that man. Poor Sinbad has to walk around for months. Right, with that man clinging onto him.
一旦他被缩小，我就像个蹦蹦跳跳的孩子，但我被涂成了绿色，我全身都是绿的，汤姆。你演的不是那个可怕的老头吗？辛巴达遇见了他，他请求辛巴达背他一程，因为他的腿很虚弱，无法行走。于是辛巴达作为一个好心人，把他背了起来，那个人就紧紧抱住他，双腿缠在他身上，辛巴达怎么也甩不掉他。我本可以演那个人。可怜的辛巴达不得不背着他走了好几个月。没错，背着那个死死缠住他的人。
Yeah. To be honest with you, Tom, I can't actually remember whether I played him or not, but there's no doubt that I could have played him. Of course you could. And I would have done it in a very moving and evocative way. You would have done. Well, we've come to the Arabian Nights, and I think that they are important because, as we've kind of touched on before, they do give to Baghdad a sense of being part of global popular culture,
是啊。老实说，汤姆，我其实记不清我到底演没演过他，但毫无疑问我完全能演。你当然能。而且我会以一种非常感人且引人入胜的方式来演绎。你肯定会的。好了，我们谈到了《一千零一夜》，我认为它们很重要，因为正如我们之前提到的，它们赋予了巴格达一种作为全球流行文化一部分的感觉，
as they have been for centuries. Because I think that Baghdad is one of those world cities that its own mythology has become part of global mythology. So, Sherlock Holmes in London, Batman in New York, Sinbad and Ali Baba are kind of on that level. Yes, I've forgotten and Ali Baba are kind of on that level. Yes. I'd forgotten about Ali Baba. Ali Baba and the 40 Thieves. So I think that they are important. So we'll look at how they, are they authentic records of Harun al-Rashid's Baghdad? Surely that story about the old man's not authentic.
正如它们几个世纪以来所呈现的那样。因为我认为巴格达是那种自身神话已成为全球神话一部分的世界城市。就像伦敦的福尔摩斯、纽约的蝙蝠侠，辛巴达和阿里巴巴也处于那个层面。是的，我忘了还有阿里巴巴。阿里巴巴和四十大盗。所以我认为它们很重要。我们将探讨它们是否是哈伦·拉希德时期巴格达的真实记录？那个关于老人的故事肯定不是真实的吧。
Well, we'll come to that. But the other thing, the passage that you read points to another reason why I think Baghdad matters. And I think it matters massively. It's a city on a level with classical Athens or Renaissance Florence as a place that has changed how the world thinks. And because of its central role in Islam, and Islam has been, is so massively influential on the course of world history, the role that Baghdad plays in shaping the way that Islam will evolve, I think is really, really crucial. Okay. Tom, just before you start, just reassure me, there's no element here of you having smuggled in a podcast about Islamic theology disguised as a podcast about Ali Baba and the 40 thieves. Well, you know I love an abstract noun. You do. You do. Absolute scenes here. The rest is history. Come on then. Well, I'm not going to apologize for it, Dominic,
嗯，我们稍后会谈到。但你读的那段文字指出了我认为巴格达重要的另一个原因。我认为它极其重要。它是一座与古典雅典或文艺复兴时期的佛罗伦萨并驾齐驱的城市，是一个改变了世界思维方式的地方。由于它在伊斯兰教中的核心地位，而伊斯兰教对世界历史进程有着巨大的影响，我认为巴格达在塑造伊斯兰教演变方式中所扮演的角色真的非常、非常关键。好了，汤姆，在你开始之前，先向我保证，这里面没有把你那关于伊斯兰神学的播客伪装成关于阿里巴巴和四十大盗的播客的成分。好吧，你知道我喜欢抽象名词。你确实喜欢。场面一度十分混乱。这是《历史的余韵》。来吧。好吧，多米尼克，我不会为此道歉，
because as I may have mentioned, the history of Christianity is obviously massively influential on the course of Western history. And so similarly, Islam is massively influential on the history of the Islamic world. I mean, that goes without saying. So it does actually matter, I think. And it enables those of us who are not part of the Islamic world to see perhaps what is distinctive about the West, things that we may take for granted. But there are other ways of conceptualizing the world, conceptualizing what states should be, how laws should function, all that kind of thing. Tom, do you know what? I could not be more excited.
因为正如我可能提到过的，基督教的历史显然对西方历史的进程有着巨大的影响。同样，伊斯兰教对伊斯兰世界的历史也有着巨大的影响。我的意思是，这不言而喻。所以我认为这确实很重要。它使我们这些非伊斯兰世界的人能够看到西方或许独特的地方，那些我们可能视为理所当然的事情。但还有其他概念化世界、概念化国家应有的样子、法律应如何运作等问题的方式。汤姆，你知道吗？我简直兴奋极了。
Oh, so crack on and satisfy my curiosity about Baghdad and its importance. So this is a hugely, hugely significant story. And it's a story that has obviously reverberated into the present, continues to reverberate. So I think it really does matter. So listeners who we've kept, if there are any from the first episode, may remember that we gave a portrait of the world before the coming of the Abbasids. So this was a world ruled by the Umayyad Caliphs. And the Umayyad Caliphs rule as self-proclaimed the deputies of God. And they are essentially in a line of tradition that goes all the way back to the autocrats of antiquity.
哦，那就开始吧，满足我对巴格达及其重要性的好奇心。这是一个非常、非常重要的故事。这个故事显然在今天依然引起共鸣，并将继续引起共鸣。所以我认为它确实很重要。如果还有从第一集坚持听下来的听众，可能还记得我们描绘了阿拔斯王朝到来之前的世界。那是一个由倭马亚哈里发统治的世界。倭马亚哈里发自称为上帝的代理人。他们本质上处于一条可以追溯到古代独裁者的传统脉络中。
I mean, ultimately back to the great kings of Persia and Babylon and Assyria. But they are increasingly challenged by a body of lawyers, of scholars, of textual critics called the ulama, who are essentially committed to the idea that Muslims should be ruled not by caliphs so much as by the rule of God, by the law of God. And the name that they give to this is the sharia, which was originally an Arabic word meaning the straightest possible path to water. So it's the idea that the Sharia will guide you through your life, through the course of existence until you can imbibe the sweet waters of paradise when you die. And how do you know where the Sharia is, how you follow it, what the course should be? You look to sunnah, which originally meant custom,
我的意思是，最终可以追溯到波斯、巴比伦和亚述的伟大国王。但他们日益受到一群被称为“乌里玛”（ulama）的律师、学者和文本批评家的挑战，这些人本质上致力于这样一种理念：穆斯林不应由哈里发统治，而应由上帝的统治、上帝的法律来统治。他们给这个概念起名为“沙里亚”（sharia），这个词最初在阿拉伯语中意为“通往水源的最直路径”。所以这个理念是，沙里亚将指引你度过一生，度过存在的历程，直到你死后能够饮用天堂的甘泉。那么你如何知道沙里亚在哪里，如何遵循它，路径应该是什么？你要看“圣训”（sunnah），它最初的意思是习俗，
but by the time of the Abbasids has come to basically mean a body of law that is capable of taming the iniquities of the age, that is fashioned without reference to the figure of the caliph, and is supposedly grounded in the life and times and particularly sayings of the prophet. And these are things called hadiths, is that right? Absolutely, yes. So these hadiths, which by the time of the Abbasids are being attributed directly to Muhammad and therefore providing a kind of a license, a sanction, an understanding of God's purposes with which the caliph can't really compete. And the Abbasid revolution had won mass support among Muslims because it was believed that it would return the Muslim people to the Sharia, that the Umayyads had, with their kind of imperious aping of Caesars and Shars, had failed do. Scholars who are interested, concerned to work out what
但到了阿拔斯王朝时期，它基本上意味着一套能够驯服时代罪恶的法律体系，它的制定无需参考哈里发，并且据称植根于先知的生平、时代，特别是他的言论。这些被称为“圣训”（hadiths），对吗？绝对正确。所以这些圣训在阿拔斯王朝时期被直接归于穆罕默德名下，从而提供了一种哈里发无法真正与之竞争的许可、制裁和对上帝旨意的理解。阿拔斯革命赢得了穆斯林群众的支持，因为人们相信它将使穆斯林人民回归沙里亚，而倭马亚王朝那种傲慢地模仿凯撒和沙阿的做法未能做到这一点。那些有兴趣、关心研究出
the correct sunnah should be, the correct custom for the Muslim people, are given a massive shot in the arm by the Abbasid revolution. Baghdad provides them with a kind of global center. It becomes the go-to place for people who are interested in all this stuff. The caliphs, partly because the sheer number of scholars who are working on this is something that is now impossible for them to regulate or control, but also because they, by virtue of the Abbasid revolution, are committed to upholding Sharia, don't really have any choice except to show the Alama more respect than the Umayyads had ever done. And so a brilliant example of how this could affect a caliph is the relationship that al-Marty, who is the son of al-Mansur, the founder of Baghdad, the father of Harun al-Rashid, and who in our last episode, listeners may remember, we talked about how he's
什么是正确的圣训、什么是穆斯林人民的正确习俗的学者们，在阿拔斯革命中得到了巨大的支持。巴格达为他们提供了一个全球中心。它成为了所有对这些东西感兴趣的人的首选之地。哈里发们，部分是因为研究这些东西的学者数量之多已让他们无法监管或控制，但也因为他们凭借阿拔斯革命，致力于维护沙里亚，除了对乌里玛表现出比倭马亚王朝更多的尊重外，别无选择。一个关于这如何影响哈里发的绝佳例子是马赫迪（al-Mahdi）与学者的关系，他是巴格达建立者曼苏尔的儿子，也是哈伦·拉希德的父亲，在上一集中，听众可能还记得，我们谈到了他
a great fan of pigeon racing. He loved a pigeon race. But he's going up there, he's getting his pigeons, he's flying them away. And then suddenly he is told by various scholars that this is illegal, that this is illicit. It's contrary to the will of God because pigeon racing was invented by the people of Sodom. What? That is a twist. And that Sodom was wiped out by God and that this was the sin of the people of Sodom was pigeon racing. I was under the impression the sin of Sodom was very different, but no. No. Well, so there are scholars who say, no, the sin of Sodom was pigeon racing. And so Almady, he's thrown into a panic by this because he doesn't want to offend the rulings of God or
是一个赛鸽迷。他热爱赛鸽。但他正准备去放飞鸽子时，突然被几位学者告知这是非法的，这是违禁的。这违背了上帝的旨意，因为赛鸽运动是由所多玛人发明的。什么？这真是个反转。所多玛被上帝毁灭了，而所多玛人的罪恶就是赛鸽。我一直以为所多玛的罪恶是非常不同的，但并没有。不。好吧，确实有学者说，不，所多玛的罪恶就是赛鸽。于是马赫迪陷入了恐慌，因为他不想触犯上帝的裁决或
indeed the scholars who are telling this. So he does the obvious thing, which is to find a scholar who can affirm that actually the prophet had been a big fan of pigeon racing. So, phew, well, that's all right. But then it turns out the scam is revealed and it turns out that the scholar has invented this hadith and it's all very embarrassing. And so al-Mahdi then is thrown into an even bigger panic and he kills his entire stock of pigeons, which is a tragic moment. Just on the hadiths, Tom, people are uncovering these hadiths, as you put it. For a sceptical non-Muslim like me, would it be reasonable to say people are simply inventing these hadiths? They're being commissioned to produce them or whatever?
那些告诉他这些的学者。所以他做了显而易见的事，那就是找一位能证实先知其实也是赛鸽迷的学者。呼，好吧，那还好。但后来骗局被揭穿了，原来那位学者编造了这条圣训，这非常尴尬。于是马赫迪陷入了更大的恐慌，他杀死了他所有的鸽子，这是一个悲剧性的时刻。关于圣训，汤姆，人们正在发掘这些圣训，正如你所说。对于像我这样的怀疑论非穆斯林来说，说人们只是在编造这些圣训是否合理？他们是被雇佣来编造这些的，或者诸如此类？
I think there are people who are doing that. But part of the scholarship that Baghdad comes to boast is a very, very disciplined and, I mean, not entirely objective, obviously, but to a degree, objective winnowing of all these hadiths. And so they inspect them for what come to be called isnad, which are kind of chains of transmission. So I heard it from this guy who heard it from this guy who heard it from this guy who heard it from the prophet. And these have to be stress tested. And the question of whether this stress testing is actually adequate is a topic of much debate among scholars of early Islam now. I mean, generally, for obvious reasons, Muslims are keener on the idea that hadiths can be
我想确实有人在这样做。但巴格达引以为傲的学术研究的一部分，是一种非常、非常严谨的——我的意思是，显然并非完全客观，但在一定程度上是客观的——对所有这些圣训的筛选。因此，他们会检查所谓的“传述链”（isnad），这是一种传播链条。比如：我从这个人那里听到，他从那个人那里听到，他从那个人那里听到，他从先知那里听到。这些必须经过压力测试。关于这种压力测试是否真正充分，现在是早期伊斯兰教研究者争论的热点。我的意思是，通常出于显而易见的原因，穆斯林更倾向于认为圣训可以是
authentic and kind of skeptical Western historians are less sure of that. But people are not naive in this period. So for instance, it's very obvious that this guy who's come up with a hadith, which Mohammed says pigeon racing is great. It's obvious it's a fake, and it's exposed as such. But equally, scholars do come to rule that actually pigeon racing is acceptable. So where things are necessary, it will be done. And actually, one of the key intellectual developments in Baghdad in this period, which is why it's so important, is the development of a science of jurisprudence, what in Arabic is called fiqh, which is how exactly do you know what the sharia is?
真实的，而持怀疑态度的西方历史学家则不太确定。但在这个时期，人们并不天真。例如，很明显，这个编造出“穆罕默德说赛鸽很棒”的圣训的人，显然是伪造的，并被揭露了。但同样，学者们也确实裁定赛鸽是可以接受的。所以，在必要的地方，事情总会得到解决。事实上，这一时期巴格达的关键智力发展之一，也是它如此重要的原因，就是法理学的发展，在阿拉伯语中称为“费格赫”（fiqh），即你究竟如何知道什么是沙里亚？
And hadiths are certainly part of it. But the first and greatest of the scholars who kind of blazed this path is a guy called Abu Hanifa, who is a silk merchant from Kufa, and who ends up buried in the Highgate Cemetery of Baghdad. We mentioned it yesterday. He basically comes to embody an entire school of understanding for how Muslims can know what the sunnah should properly be. So various stories are told about this guy. Some stories say that he was kind of the principal advisor to al-Mansur with the founding of Baghdad. Others say that al-Mansur put him to death because he wouldn't serve as a
圣训当然是其中的一部分。但开创这条道路的第一位也是最伟大的学者是一个叫阿布·哈尼法（Abu Hanifa）的人，他是一位来自库法的丝绸商人，最终被安葬在巴格达的海格特公墓。我们昨天提到过。他基本上体现了穆斯林如何了解什么是正确圣训的整个理解流派。关于这个人流传着各种故事。有些故事说他是曼苏尔建立巴格达时的主要顾问。另一些则说曼苏尔处死了他，因为他不愿担任
judge because he was far too busy with his scholarship. So he's a kind of legendary figure. But his tomb still stands in Baghdad to this day. It's much admired and respected. And what Abu Hanifa emphasizes is the role that reason plays. That reason is a gift from God, and therefore you can use reason to arrive at an understanding of what God's purposes should properly be. And this is obviously very useful for the caliphs because they're trying to balance the requirements of piety with day-to-day convenience. The Hanafites, as they come to be called, this school, are very, very useful to them. But there is religious opposition to this because, for instance, the pigeon racing would be an example.
法官，因为他太忙于学术研究了。所以他是一个传奇人物。但他的陵墓至今仍矗立在巴格达。它备受推崇和尊敬。阿布·哈尼法强调了理性所扮演的角色。理性是上帝的恩赐，因此你可以利用理性来得出对上帝旨意的理解。这对哈里发们显然非常有用，因为他们试图在虔诚的要求与日常便利之间取得平衡。哈尼法派（Hanafites），正如他们后来被称为的那样，这个流派对他们非常、非常有帮助。但对此存在宗教反对意见，例如，赛鸽就是一个例子。
Another example would be the license that the Hanafites give to people who want to get drunk. And they say, well, okay, you can't drink wine, but you can drink date wine. So you can't drink alcohol that's made from grapes, but you can from dates. And there's a notorious ruling that derives from this, that you can drink until you can't distinguish between a beautiful girl and a beautiful boy. So, I mean, this is not at all what the mainstream of the Hanafites are about, or Abu Hanif himself. I mean, they are very austere, pious, dutiful Muslims. But there is a feeling among some Muslim scholars that they're going a bit far. And so you get rival schools. So you get one that's centered in Medina. A guy called Malik ibn Anas is the head of that school. And he kind of emphasizes that you've got to study what the customs were in Medina and indeed Mecca. So there's this kind
另一个例子是哈尼法派给予那些想喝醉的人的许可。他们说，好吧，你不能喝葡萄酒，但你可以喝枣酒。所以你不能喝用葡萄酿造的酒精，但可以用枣酿造。由此产生了一个臭名昭著的裁决，即你可以喝到无法分辨出美丽的女孩和美丽的男孩。所以，我的意思是，这根本不是哈尼法派主流或阿布·哈尼法本人所主张的。我的意思是，他们是非常严谨、虔诚、尽职的穆斯林。但一些穆斯林学者确实觉得他们有点走得太远了。于是出现了竞争流派。比如以麦地那为中心的流派，一个叫马利克·伊本·阿纳斯（Malik ibn Anas）的人是该流派的领袖。他强调你必须研究麦地那乃至麦加的习俗。所以有这种
of emphasis on the role that is played by Muhammad much more than the Hanafites emphasize. You have a guy called Al-Shafi, who is in Cairo, who emphasizes the absolute significance of Hadiths. And you have a guy called Ibn Hanbal, who is based in Baghdad, and he compiles the most authoritative body of Hadiths. And these are very, very significant figures because these schools come to dominate in different parts of the Islamic world. So the Hanafites, they're still kind of preeminent in Turkey, in Egypt, in Pakistan, in much of Central Asia. But the Malachites provide the understanding of the Sunnah to North Africa. And the Hanbalites are very, very strong influence on Saudi Arabia.
对穆罕默德所扮演角色的强调，远超哈尼法派的强调。你有一个在开罗的叫沙斐仪（Al-Shafi）的人，他强调圣训的绝对重要性。还有一个在巴格达的叫伊本·罕百里（Ibn Hanbal）的人，他编纂了最权威的圣训集。这些都是非常、非常重要的人物，因为这些流派在伊斯兰世界的不同地区占据了主导地位。所以哈尼法派在土耳其、埃及、巴基斯坦、中亚大部分地区仍然占据优势。但马利克派为北非提供了对圣训的理解。而罕百里派对沙特阿拉伯有着非常、非常强的影响。
And so it's often said that the kind of Islamic radicalism that has been roiling the world over the past two decades is essentially Hanbalite. So you can see how these understandings of Islam that develop in this period, I mean, they are really quite significant in their influence. And what about the idea of the law more generally, Tom? So if I'm reading your notes correctly, the idea of there being a law that exists outside the state, indeed that precedes the invention of the state is massively important for Islam. Yes, because Islam, so in Christianity, there is no body of law that is given by God to Christians. The law exists in the heart, in the form of conscience, and that means that it's entirely acceptable. I mean, we take for granted that different states would have different frameworks of law. But for Muslim scholars in the Abbasid Caliphate, this kind of represents everything that makes Christianity kind of hopeless, because it means
所以人们常说，过去二十年来搅动世界的伊斯兰激进主义本质上是罕百里派的。所以你可以看出，在这一时期发展的这些对伊斯兰教的理解，我的意思是，它们的影响确实非常显著。那么关于法律更广泛的概念呢，汤姆？如果我没读错你的笔记，存在于国家之外、甚至先于国家发明而存在的法律这一理念，对伊斯兰教来说是极其重要的。是的，因为在基督教中，没有上帝赐予基督徒的法律体系。法律存在于心中，以良知的形式存在，这意味着它是完全可以接受的。我的意思是，我们认为不同的国家会有不同的法律框架是理所当然的。但对于阿拔斯哈里发国的穆斯林学者来说，这代表了使基督教显得无望的一切，因为它意味着
that if you have different systems of law, then it's constantly changing and rules of conduct will fluctuate according to the rulers or to circumstances or to the whims and fashions of the people who are being governed. Whereas the whole point of the law that Islam has received from God is that it provides a secure and certain way of living. The corollary in turn of that is that law is not the invention of man, but of God, and therefore, precedes any state. In fact, states exist, if of God, and therefore precedes any state. And in fact, states exist, if you like, to maintain and apply the law. So it's a very different understanding
如果你有不同的法律体系，那么它就会不断变化，行为准则会根据统治者、环境或被统治者的心血来潮和时尚而波动。而伊斯兰教从上帝那里接受的法律的全部意义在于，它提供了一种安全且确定的生活方式。反过来，其推论是法律不是人的发明，而是上帝的发明，因此先于任何国家。事实上，国家存在，如果
of the relationship of state and law to one that comes to dominate in the West. And I think, again, it kind of explains a huge amount about the chasm of misunderstanding that has been for so long operated between the West and the Islamic world. And simply in terms of the Abbasid period, the golden age of Baghdad that we've been talking about, it obviously has long-term implications for the caliph, this idea that states exist really only to uphold the law of God. Because if these scholars are the key figures in interpreting and defining the law of God, then what's the role of the caliph?
是为了维护和应用法律。所以这与西方占主导地位的对国家与法律关系的理解非常不同。我认为，这再次解释了西方与伊斯兰世界之间长期存在的误解鸿沟。仅仅就阿拔斯时期、我们一直在谈论的巴格达黄金时代而言，这种“国家存在实际上只是为了维护上帝的法律”的理念对哈里发显然有长期的影响。因为如果这些学者是解释和定义上帝法律的关键人物，那么哈里发的角色是什么？
Yes. So the figure of the caliph in the wake of the golden age of Baghdad over the course of the centuries that will culminate in the capture of the last Abbasid caliph and him being trampled to death by the cavalry of the Mongols. Basically, he ends up a cipher, the figure of the caliph. So that's the importance of Baghdad on Islam, on the world of Islam. What about for the West? Because you have an argument, don't you, that you think Baghdad really mattered in the course of Western history as well? It does, yes. So obviously, the
是的。所以，在巴格达黄金时代之后，经过几个世纪的演变，最终以最后一个阿拔斯哈里发被俘并被蒙古骑兵践踏致死而告终，哈里发的形象基本上变成了一个虚位。这就是巴格达对伊斯兰教、对伊斯兰世界的重要性。那么对西方呢？因为你有一个观点，不是吗，你认为巴格达在西方历史进程中也确实很重要？确实如此，是的。所以显然，
development of the various Islamic schools, the Sunni schools, hugely influential on Islam. But yes, Baghdad is also massively influential on intellectual trends in Christendom, in Western Christendom. This role that Baghdad has is summed up by a very romantic phrase, the house of wisdom. The house of wisdom serves as shorthand for a remarkable process of translation in which almost all the writings from ancient Greek, except for literature and except for history, so no Homer, no Herodotus, no Aeschylus or Aristophanes, but basically everything else. Astrolog astrology, alchemy, philosophy, botany, books on military science, falconry. I mean, everything is translated. And this is an immense and basically
各种伊斯兰流派、逊尼派流派的发展，对伊斯兰教影响巨大。但没错，巴格达对基督教世界、西方基督教世界的思想潮流也影响巨大。巴格达所扮演的这个角色被一个非常浪漫的短语所概括：智慧宫（House of Wisdom）。智慧宫是这一非凡翻译过程的代名词，几乎所有古希腊著作，除了文学和历史——所以没有荷马、没有希罗多德、没有埃斯库罗斯或阿里斯托芬，但基本上其他所有东西：占星术、炼金术、哲学、植物学、军事科学书籍、猎鹰术。我的意思是，一切都被翻译了。这是一个巨大且基本上
unique project. I mean, nothing like it had happened. In the episode we did on the Library of Alexandria, we talked about how actually there is no great translation project there. The Library of Alexandria is interested in books in Greek. But the Abbasids, when I say Abbasids, I mean it's not just the caliphs, it's the entire elite. So it's the viziers, generals, merchants, bankers, Arabs, non-Arabs, Muslims, non-Muslims, Sunnis, Shias, basically everybody is committed to this project. It enables it to be funded, and it enables it to be done to really, really exacting standards. The scholar who's written most interestingly on this is a guy called Dimitri Goutas, who's written this fantastic book on it, Greek Thought, Arabic Culture. He sums up its significance that it's a truly
独特的工程。我的意思是，从未发生过类似的事情。在我们关于亚历山大图书馆的那一集中，我们谈到了那里实际上没有伟大的翻译工程。亚历山大图书馆对希腊语书籍感兴趣。但阿拔斯人，当我说是阿拔斯人时，我的意思是不仅仅是哈里发，而是整个精英阶层。所以是维齐尔、将军、商人、银行家、阿拉伯人、非阿拉伯人、穆斯林、非穆斯林、逊尼派、什叶派，基本上每个人都致力于这个工程。这使得它能够获得资助，并能以非常、非常严苛的标准完成。对此写得最有趣的研究者是一个叫迪米特里·古塔斯（Dimitri Goutas）的人，他写了一本关于此的精彩著作《希腊思想，阿拉伯文化》。他总结了其重要性，称其为人类历史上
epoch-making stage by any standard in the course of human history. It is equal in significance to and belongs to the same narrative as, I would claim, that of Pericles' Athens, the Italian Renaissance, or the scientific revolution of the 16th and 17th centuries, and it deserves so to be recognised and embedded in our historical consciousness. So that's what we're doing in this episode, Dominic. Yeah. Very good. Yeah.
任何标准下都具有划时代意义的阶段。我主张，它在重要性上与伯里克利的雅典、意大利文艺复兴或 16 世纪和 17 世纪的科学革命相当，并属于同一叙事，它理应得到认可并嵌入我们的历史意识中。所以这就是我们在这一集中所做的，多米尼克。是的。非常好。是的。
Now, why are they doing it? Are they doing it because they are keen to learn from the Greeks? Are they doing it because they're just interested in a kind of Enlightenment project? What does Dimitri Guttas think? So there is very much a kind of an idea that it's a proto-enlightenment. You will often read that it's learning for learning's sake. It's an attempt to dispel the clouds of darkness, and to a degree it is. But I don't think that it can be explained. And when I say I, I mean Dimitri Guttas' argument is that there is no one explanation for this, that it's a combination of circumstance and motive. The circumstance is the collapse of the border that had existed between the Persian and the Roman empires with the coming of Islam.
现在，他们为什么要这样做？他们这样做是因为他们渴望向希腊人学习吗？他们这样做是因为他们只是对某种启蒙工程感兴趣吗？迪米特里·古塔斯怎么看？确实有一种“它是原始启蒙运动”的观点。你经常会读到这是为了学习而学习。这是一种驱散黑暗云层的尝试，在某种程度上确实如此。但我认为它不能被单一解释。当我说是“我”时，我的意思是迪米特里·古塔斯的论点是，对此没有单一的解释，它是环境和动机的结合。环境是随着伊斯兰教的到来，波斯帝国和罗马帝国之间存在的边界的崩溃。
All of the Near East is governed by a single power. That means that scholars on both sides of what had previously been a bit of an iron curtain can now communicate with one another. These people are usually multilingual. They are specialists in entire areas of learning. This is an enormous resource that can be tapped. And it seems that the moment Baghdad is founded, scholars from across the Near East are kind of zooming in on Baghdad. Now, why are they going there? Essentially, because they know that they're going to get sponsorship, which in turn begs the question, well, why are they sure of that? Part of it, I think, is that we talked about how Al-Mansur has this ambition to make Baghdad a universal city in terms of time as well as space, that he wants to fold in the learning
整个近东由单一权力统治。这意味着以前那道铁幕两边的学者现在可以相互交流了。这些人通常精通多种语言。他们是整个学习领域的专家。这是一个可以利用的巨大资源。似乎巴格达一建立，来自整个近东的学者就蜂拥而至。现在，他们为什么要到那里去？本质上是因为他们知道他们会得到赞助，这反过来又引出了一个问题，好吧，为什么他们对此如此确定？我认为部分原因是，我们谈到了曼苏尔有志于使巴格达成为一座在时间和空间上都具有普遍性的城市，他想将以前非伊斯兰文明的学识
and achievements of previously non-Islamic civilizations into Baghdad so that they can serve the greater glory of Islam. And that means that he is interested in all ancient civilizations. So not just the Greeks, but the Persian as well. And again, I think if there's been a theme throughout these episodes, it's the importance of Persian culture on the making of Baghdad. So a lot of the first Greek texts to be translated are actually written in Persian. And House of Wisdom, Beit al-Hikmah, was actually the Persian Sasanian word for a library. So that's what it is. So the House of Wisdom is probably founded by Almanzor in Baghdad, in very, very self-conscious emulation of the Persian example. That's what he's trying to do.
和成就融入巴格达，以便它们能为伊斯兰教的更大荣耀服务。这意味着他对所有古代文明都感兴趣。所以不仅是希腊，还有波斯。同样，我认为如果这些集数中有一个主题，那就是波斯文化对巴格达形成的重要性。所以许多第一批被翻译的希腊文本实际上是用波斯语写的。而“智慧宫”（Beit al-Hikmah）实际上是波斯萨珊王朝对图书馆的称呼。所以这就是它。所以智慧宫很可能是曼苏尔在巴格达建立的，非常、非常有意识地效仿了波斯的先例。这就是他试图做的。
And it exists specifically to house books that have been translated not from Greek, but from Persian. So these are translations of Persian translations of Greek. So the House of Wisdom is not a center for the translation of writings from Greek. It's not a research center. It's not a kind of conference center where scholars meet up. It is basically a library, as the Library of Alexandria was. But with the establishment of that, you have other caliphs who come in and they all have their own motives. So al-Mahdi, the pigeon racer, he's a very devout Muslim. He's very concerned to purify and clarify Muslims' understanding of their faith. So he has a lot of debates with the Christian patriarch, Timothy, who has been invited to set up shop in Baghdad. In the course of these debates, it's evident,
它存在的目的专门是为了存放不是从希腊语翻译过来，而是从波斯语翻译过来的书籍。所以这些是波斯语翻译的希腊语译本。所以智慧宫不是一个翻译希腊著作的中心。它不是一个研究中心。它不是一个学者们会面的会议中心。它基本上就是一个图书馆，就像亚历山大图书馆一样。但随着它的建立，其他哈里发也加入了进来，他们都有自己的动机。所以赛鸽迷马赫迪，他是一位非常虔诚的穆斯林。他非常关心净化和澄清穆斯林对他们信仰的理解。所以他与基督教牧首提摩太（Timothy）进行了很多辩论，后者受邀在巴格达设立据点。在这些辩论的过程中，显而易见，
I think, that al-Mahdi realizes how much Christian theology has benefited from its immersion in Greek philosophy, so in Plato, but also particularly Aristotle. He's the first caliph to commission translations of Aristotle directly from Greek. I think he is doing that rather in the spirit that the Chinese today might steal intellectual property from Stanford University or something like that. There's a verse in the Quran that says the Romans have been defeated, but they will be triumphant in the short term. Is that to be reckoned to have existed from eternity? Because if it is, it means that the defeat of the Romans was preordained. Whereas if it's created, then it means that the Romans had
我认为，马赫迪意识到基督教神学从其对希腊哲学、即柏拉图，但也特别是亚里士多德的沉浸中受益匪浅。他是第一位直接委托从希腊语翻译亚里士多德著作的哈里发。我认为他这样做更像是今天中国可能会从斯坦福大学窃取知识产权之类的精神。古兰经中有一节经文说罗马人被击败了，但他们会在短期内取得胜利。这是否被认为是从永恒中就存在的？因为如果是这样，这意味着罗马人的失败是命中注定的。而如果是被创造的，那么这意味着罗马人拥有
free will and all Muslims have free will. It's rather like debates that you get in Calvin or Augustine and Christian theology. It's a debate about the degree to which people have free will. And Greek philosophy is seen by Al-Mamun as a way to kind of back up his own take. But there's also another reason why Al-Mamun in particular is keen to sponsor all these translations, which is that by this time, he's kind of waging an intellectual war against Byzantium and casting the Byzantines as unworthy of their inheritance. That essentially, he wants to cast the Muslims as the heirs of ancient Greek wisdom and to say the Byzantines have totally squandered it because they've got this mad kind of understanding of
自由意志，所有穆斯林都拥有自由意志。这很像你在加尔文或奥古斯丁和基督教神学中看到的辩论。这是一场关于人们拥有多少自由意志的辩论。希腊哲学被马蒙（Al-Mamun）视为一种支持他自己观点的方式。但马蒙特别热衷于赞助所有这些翻译还有另一个原因，那就是到这个时候，他正在对拜占庭发动一场智力战争，并将拜占庭人描绘成不配继承遗产的人。本质上，他想把穆斯林塑造成古希腊智慧的继承者，并说拜占庭人已经完全挥霍了它，因为他们对
Christianity and it's all hopeless. So, I mean, these are all Goethe's arguments, but I think you can see there a pretty convincing case that a single, oh, they did it because they loved wisdom or something like that is inadequate. Each caliph has a different reason for promoting this incredible project of translation. It matters for Christendom and therefore the West because, as well as philosophy, there are also what we would ultimately perhaps come to call scientific treatises being translated. These, in turn, will help to foster an incredibly vibrant scientific and philosophical tradition, which because Al-Andalus in Spain, the caliphate in Spain, is not politically part of the Abbasid caliphate, but they're part of the same world. And so all these works that
基督教有一种疯狂的理解，一切都毫无希望。所以，我的意思是，这些都是古塔斯的论点，但我认为你可以从中看到一个非常有说服力的案例，即“哦，他们这样做是因为他们热爱智慧”之类的单一解释是不够的。每位哈里发都有不同的理由来推动这个令人难以置信的翻译工程。这对基督教世界、进而对西方很重要，因为除了哲学，还有我们最终可能称之为科学论文的东西被翻译。这些反过来将有助于培养一种极其活跃的科学和哲学传统，因为安达卢斯（西班牙的哈里发国）在政治上不是阿拔斯哈里发国的一部分，但他们属于同一个世界。所以所有这些
are being penned by Arabic scholars, be they philosophical or be they treatises on eye surgery or other aspects of medicine or mathematics. I mean, algebra, of course, is an Arabic word. Astrology, alchemy, everything. When Christians conquer Spain, they will be able to set up their own house of translation in Toledo and get access to these incredible riches, which in turn will help kind of fuel intellectual traditions in medieval Christian Europe. Brilliant. So Tom, do you know what you haven't mentioned? I'm so happy you haven't mentioned this because it allows me to share this myself with the listeners. People who love literature will know that in the story, The Thief Who Stole Nothing, Biff, Chip and Kipper visited medieval Baghdad, Tom, and they
由阿拉伯学者撰写的著作，无论是哲学著作，还是关于眼科手术或其他医学或数学方面的论文。我的意思是，代数当然是一个阿拉伯词。占星术、炼金术，一切。当基督徒征服西班牙时，他们将能够建立自己的托莱多翻译院，并获得这些令人难以置信的财富，这反过来将有助于推动中世纪基督教欧洲的智力传统。太棒了。那么汤姆，你知道你没提到什么吗？我很高兴你没提到这个，因为这让我可以亲自与听众分享。热爱文学的人会知道，在《什么都没偷的小偷》这个故事中，比夫、奇普和基珀（Biff, Chip and Kipper）访问了中世纪的巴格达，汤姆，他们
went to the House of Wisdom and they discussed early mathematics with Islamic scholars. So for people who don't have children at primary school in England, these are horrendous series. No, they're brilliant. That's absolute idiocy. No, they're terrible. They're absolutely terrible. That's the worst thing you've ever said in this podcast, to knock Biff, Chip and Kipper. No, they're terrible. They're absolutely terrible. That's the worst thing you've ever said in this podcast, to knock Biff, Chip and Kipper. No, they're terrible. They're absolutely terrible. Hello, Biff, said Kipper. No, rubbish. You invited yourself to my house on Mother's Day.
去了智慧宫，并与伊斯兰学者讨论了早期数学。所以对于那些在英国没有上小学的孩子的人来说，这些是可怕的系列。不，它们很棒。那简直是白痴行为。不，它们很糟糕。它们绝对糟糕。这是你在本播客中说过的最糟糕的话，去抨击比夫、奇普和基珀。不，它们很糟糕。它们绝对糟糕。你好，比夫，基珀说。不，垃圾。你在母亲节那天不请自来地去了我家。
Yeah. Do you remember that? For lunch? Yeah, I do. Yeah. And Arthur was reading the Time Chronicles, which are the sequels to Biff, Chip and Kipper, and you and Sadie were beside yourselves with excitement that Biff, Chip and Kipper was merely preparing the ground for more important adventures later on. Well, that's because we never got onto it. Listen, what's it called?
是啊。你还记得吗？去吃午饭？是的，我记得。是的。亚瑟当时正在读《时间编年史》，那是比夫、奇普和基珀的续集，你和萨迪当时兴奋得不得了，因为比夫、奇普和基珀只是在为以后更重要的冒险做铺垫。好吧，那是因为我们从来没谈到它。听着，它叫什么名字？
The Thief Who Stole Nothing. I heartily recommend it to the listeners. It's a brilliant, brilliant way of getting into the world of medieval Baghdad. And on that bombshell, we're going to go to the break, and when we come back, finally, we're going to go to the break. And when we come back, finally, we're going to get to the Arabian Nights. All right.
《什么都没偷的小偷》。我衷心向听众推荐它。这是进入中世纪巴格达世界的一种非常、非常棒的方式。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们要去休息一下，当我们回来时，终于，我们要去休息一下。当我们回来时，终于，我们要谈谈《一千零一夜》了。好的。
Okay. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
好的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余韵》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、加更节目、
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. At last, the moment is upon us. Ali Baba and the 40 Thieves, Sinbad and the Rock, Aladdin and his lamp. Tom Holland is poised to take us into the perfume-scented world. But it's not all just perfume and scent, is it? Because it's out in the streets, the mean streets, a lot of violence, a lot of sex. So if you're a child and you read kind of bad-rized versions of them, you have no idea just how violent and often very rude these stories are. Well, Tom Tennyson wrote about the Arabian Nights, didn't he? When the breeze of a joyful dawn blew free in the silken sail of infancy,
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余韵》。终于，这一刻到来了。阿里巴巴和四十大盗、辛巴达和大鹏鸟、阿拉丁和他的神灯。汤姆·霍兰德准备带我们进入那个香气四溢的世界。但这不仅仅是香水和气味，对吧？因为它发生在街道上，那些卑劣的街道，充满了暴力和性。所以如果你是一个孩子，读的是那种删减版，你根本不知道这些故事有多暴力，而且往往非常粗俗。好吧，丁尼生写过《一千零一夜》，不是吗？当欢乐黎明的微风自由吹拂，在婴儿期的丝绸帆上，
the tide of time flowed back with me, the flowing tide of time and it goes on and on i'm not gonna read the whole thing but it's all about gardens and yeah the golden prime of good harun al rashid says tennyson yeah so there is a sense i think in which in the west the understanding of the arabian nights is very clouded by the fact that it has become a very distinctive Western tradition. Yes. So Victorians loved it. They were always doing translations of it and illustrations of it. So pre-Raphaelite paintings and stuff. All that kind of stuff, yes. There is an argument, and it's been made sometimes by scholars of the Arabian Nights, that the Arabian Nights as we understand them in the West
时间的潮汐随我回流，时间的流动潮汐，它还在继续，我不会读完整首诗，但它全是关于花园，是的，好哈伦·拉希德的黄金时代，丁尼生说，是的。所以我认为在西方，对《一千零一夜》的理解在很大程度上被它已成为一种非常独特的西方传统这一事实所掩盖。是的。维多利亚时代的人很喜欢它。他们总是做它的翻译和插图。所以前拉斐尔派的画作之类的东西。所有这些，是的。有一种观点，有时由《一千零一夜》的学者提出，即我们西方人所理解的《一千零一夜》
are pretty much a kind of Western invention. And that reflects the fact that they, by and large, are much more popular in the West. They've been much more influential than they've been in the Islamic world, paradoxically. And that's due to the impact of the first guy who translated them into a European language, who is a man called Antoine Gallon, who lived between 1646 and 1715, who was a brilliant linguist. He came from Picardy. And because of his capacity for languages, his mastery of tongues dominated. He gets taken by the French ambassador to the sublime port in Constantinople in 1670. And there he very rapidly learns Arabic. He learns Turkish as well. He learns Persian. He has access to all these tales. He goes back to Paris. He works on the first great
在很大程度上是一种西方发明。这反映了这样一个事实：它们在西方总体上要受欢迎得多。矛盾的是，它们在西方的影响力比在伊斯兰世界要大得多。这归功于第一个将它们翻译成欧洲语言的人的影响，他是一个叫安托万·加朗（Antoine Gallon）的人，生活在 1646 年到 1715 年之间，他是一位天才的语言学家。他来自皮卡第。由于他精通语言，掌握了多种方言。1670 年，他被法国大使带到君士坦丁堡的最高朴特（Sublime Porte）。在那里，他很快学会了阿拉伯语。他还学会了土耳其语。他学会了波斯语。他接触到了所有这些故事。他回到巴黎。他致力于第一部伟大的
Western encyclopedia of Islam, the Bibliothèque Orientale. He writes the introduction to that. In it, he says, why is it that people in the West are so much more interested in the Islamic world than Muslims seem to be in the Western world? And his answer to this is that it's because the literature of the Arab world is perfect. It's self-sufficient. It doesn't need to bother itself with anything else. What a cultural cringe that is. How interesting. It really is interesting. It's such a contrast to today. To demonstrate this, he then embarks on a process of translating some of the tales that he's come across. In 1701, he embarks on a translation of the tales of Sinbad the Sailor, which originally had not been part of the Arabian
伊斯兰百科全书，即《东方图书馆》。他为该书撰写了序言。在序言中，他问道：为什么西方人对伊斯兰世界的兴趣，远超穆斯林对西方世界的兴趣？他的回答是，因为阿拉伯世界的文学是完美的。它是自给自足的，不需要去理会其他任何事物。这真是一种文化上的自卑。多么有趣。这确实很有趣。这与今天形成了鲜明的对比。为了证明这一点，他开始着手翻译他所遇到的一些故事。1701年，他开始翻译《辛巴达航海记》，这些故事最初并不属于《阿拉伯之夜》
Nights, but will of course become bundled into the Arabian Nights. Then he starts on the Arabian Nights proper, which is an enormous kind of vast vast body of different stories and massively long takes him 16 years comes out in 12 volumes and is an enormous enormous success and in a way it's the kind of the greatest collection of short stories ever written and it has this brilliant framing narrative that I'm sure most people remember, just in case you don't. There's this king of Persia. So again, keep Persia in your mind. He's a king called Sharia, ironically. And he discovers that his wife has been carrying on with a slave in the kitchens. And he's furious about this. And then
的一部分，但后来当然被收录进了《阿拉伯之夜》。接着，他开始翻译《阿拉伯之夜》正本，这是一部极其庞大、内容极其丰富的不同故事集，篇幅巨大，他花了16年时间，最终出版了12卷，并取得了巨大的成功。在某种程度上，它是史上最伟大的短篇小说集，而且它有一个绝妙的框架叙事，我相信大多数人都记得，以防万一你不记得了。故事里有一位波斯国王。所以，再次提醒，请记住波斯。他是一位名叫沙里亚尔的国王，讽刺的是。他发现他的妻子一直与厨房里的奴隶私通。他对此感到愤怒。然后
he finds that his brother similarly has been cuckolded. And so he's convinced that all women are naturally depraved and are bound to betray any man who sleeps with them. So his solution to this is the very reasonable one, that he will only take virgins to bed with him. And then having slept with them, he will then have them beheaded in the morning to ensure that he won't be betrayed. And he reached the stage where there simply aren't any virgins left. So he turns to his vizier who has two daughters and the elder daughter, Sherazade, says that she
他发现他的兄弟也同样被戴了绿帽子。于是他确信所有的女人天生都是堕落的，注定会背叛任何与她们同床的男人。所以他的解决方案非常“合理”，那就是他只娶处女为妻。然后，在与她们同床共枕后，他会在第二天早上将她们斩首，以确保自己不会被背叛。他达到了一个地步，那就是已经没有处女可娶了。于是他转向他的维齐尔（宰相），宰相有两个女儿，大女儿谢赫拉莎德说她
will step up to the plate and save the women who otherwise the king will murder. And she asks the king, can I have my sister, Dunyazade, with me? And he says, yes. And Sherazade gets Danyasada to say, can I have a story? And the king says, fine. Yeah. Okay. And so Sherazade starts on a story and then it's just reaching the climax as it were, and she drops it. And the king is desperate and says, but I've got to know what happens. And Sherazadeh says, well, you'll have to wait till the following night. And that of course means that she's spared execution. And so it continues for a thousand and one nights, Dominic. That's three years. And these stories are, you know, incredible range of topics. You know, there are characters within the stories that tell stories and there are characters within the stories that tell stories, and there are characters within those stories that in turn tell stories, and so it goes on.
愿意挺身而出，拯救那些本会被国王杀害的女性。她请求国王：“能让我妹妹杜尼亚莎德和我在一起吗？”国王答应了。谢赫拉莎德让杜尼亚莎德说：“能给我讲个故事吗？”国王说：“好吧，行。”于是谢赫拉莎德开始讲一个故事，讲到高潮部分时，她停了下来。国王急切地问：“但我必须知道接下来发生了什么。”谢赫拉莎德说：“好吧，你得等到第二天晚上。”这当然意味着她免于被处决。就这样，故事持续了一千零一夜，多米尼克。那是三年时间。这些故事涵盖了令人难以置信的广泛主题。故事里的人物会讲故事，故事里的人物讲的故事里还有人物在讲故事，故事里的人物讲的故事里的人物又在讲故事，就这样一直延续下去。
You have romance, adventure, low life, high life, poetry, pornography. I mean, everything is there. So incredibly vivid and brilliant collection of stories. And Tom, obviously, your description raises the possibility that these are not ultimately medieval Arabic stories or indeed Persian stories, but they might have been invented by Galland. Maybe the germ of them was there, the genesis, but he honed them and turned them into something palatable for a 17th century French readership.
你有浪漫、冒险、底层生活、上层生活、诗歌、色情。我的意思是，应有尽有。这是一个极其生动、精彩的故事集。汤姆，显然你的描述提出了这样一种可能性：这些故事最终可能并非中世纪的阿拉伯故事，甚至也不是波斯故事，而是加朗（Galland）编造的。也许它们的萌芽、起源确实存在，但他润色了它们，使之成为17世纪法国读者能够接受的东西。
Is there some truth in that? I think he does definitely bowdlerize some of them. It is a criticism, even when they come out. I mean, people say, I suspect that the court of Harun al-Rashid is more influenced by Versailles than by the actual medieval Baghdad. He definitely adds in some stories that were not originally part of it. So Sinbad is one, but perhaps the two most famous Arabian Nights stories, Aladdin and Ali Baba and the Forty Thieves, they weren't part of the original Arabian Nights either. They were told to Galen by a Maronite, so a Christian Syrian storyteller, and he thought they were so great that he put them in.
这其中有道理吗？我认为他确实对其中一些故事进行了删改。即使在它们刚出版时，这也是一种批评。我的意思是，人们说，我怀疑哈伦·拉希德的宫廷更多是受到凡尔赛宫的影响，而不是真实的中世纪巴格达。他确实加入了一些最初并不属于其中的故事。辛巴达就是一个例子，但也许《阿拉伯之夜》中最著名的两个故事——《阿拉丁》和《阿里巴巴与四十大盗》——最初也不属于《阿拉伯之夜》。它们是一位马龙派教徒，也就是一位叙利亚基督徒讲故事的人告诉加朗的，他觉得这些故事太棒了，就把它们放了进去。
So over the course of time, many more translations are done, particularly into English. And so perhaps the most notorious translation is by Sir Richard Burton, who's a terrible man. He famously disguises himself and goes to Mecca. Actually, he'd be a great subject for an episode. But Robert Irwin has a brilliant sentence about his translation and the stories that Burton has added to it. As far as I can tell, there is no Arab original for the story of how Abu Hassan break wind. So there are certainly European additions to the corpus of the Arabian Nights. But having said that, the text that Galland translates is original. And in fact, it's the oldest complete Arabic text that we have of them.
随着时间的推移，人们进行了更多的翻译，特别是翻译成英语。其中最臭名昭著的译本可能要数理查德·伯顿爵士的译本，他是个糟糕的人。他以乔装打扮去麦加而闻名。事实上，他会是一个很好的节目主题。但罗伯特·欧文关于他的译本以及伯顿加入其中的故事有一句精彩的评价。据我所知，关于阿布·哈桑放屁的故事并没有阿拉伯语原文。所以《阿拉伯之夜》的语料库中确实存在欧洲人的增补。但话虽如此，加朗翻译的文本是原始的。事实上，它是我们现存最古老的完整阿拉伯语文本。
I think it dates from the 14th century. But it's clear evidence that these stories are actually very, very old. So although lots of them are set in Cairo, probably written in the 14th or 15th centuries, because these stories describe places that weren't built until then. A substantial number of the stories in the Arabian Nights do indeed seem to go back to Abbasid Baghdad. So al-Masudi, who we've already mentioned, he mentions them in the 10th century and he name checks Sherazadeh. So we know that these stories are current then. And again, in the 10th century, there's a book collector, a guy who compiles literary lists called Ibn al-Nadim, who intriguingly reports that the original source
我认为它可追溯到14世纪。但这清楚地证明了这些故事实际上非常非常古老。所以，尽管其中许多故事以开罗为背景，可能写于14世纪或15世纪，因为这些故事描述的地方直到那时才建成。但《阿拉伯之夜》中相当多的故事似乎确实可以追溯到阿拔斯王朝时期的巴格达。所以，我们已经提到的马苏第，他在10世纪就提到了它们，并点名提到了谢赫拉莎德。所以我们知道这些故事在当时就很流行。同样在10世纪，有一位图书收藏家，一个汇编文学书目的人叫伊本·纳迪姆，他有趣地报告说，《阿拉伯之夜》的原始来源
for the Arabian Nights was, again, in the Sasanian Empire, the Persian Empire that existed before the coming of the Arabs, and that it had originally been called not the 1001 Nights, but 1000 Nights. And if you read them and you have any familiarity with Greek stories, you will recognize, I think, lots of Greek antecedents. So Sinbad, I think there are trace elements of the Odyssey in that. There's an account of a thief in the Arabian Nights who shaves the side of guards who've been posted to look after treasure, which is a story that ultimately seems to come from Herodotus. Very exciting. But does it come from Herodotus, or do they perhaps share a common source? So these may be stories that are being told across
同样是在萨珊帝国，即阿拉伯人到来之前存在的波斯帝国，而且它最初的名字不是《一千零一夜》，而是《一千个夜晚》。如果你读过这些故事，并且对希腊故事有任何了解，我想你会认出许多希腊的先例。比如辛巴达，我认为其中有《奥德赛》的痕迹。在《阿拉伯之夜》中有一个关于小偷的故事，他剃掉了被派去守卫宝藏的守卫的头发，这个故事最终似乎来自希罗多德。非常令人兴奋。但它真的来自希罗多德吗？还是他们可能共享一个共同的来源？所以这些故事可能是流传在
the Eurasian world. Sure. Yes. I'm sure that's true. But I think that there are distinctive cultural traditions that are meeting in Baghdad. So there are Greek traditions. There are people who know stories from Herodotus or Homer, and these are not being translated. So these would be oral traditions. There are Indian traditions. There are traditions that come perhaps from Mesopotamian culture, going back to Babylon. So the corpus of the Arabian Nights, I think it starts to be compiled definitely in Baghdad. But the idea of a woman telling stories to stop herself being killed comes from
整个欧亚大陆的故事。当然。是的，我相信这是真的。但我认为在巴格达汇聚了独特的文化传统。有希腊传统。有些人知道来自希罗多德或荷马的故事，而这些故事并没有被翻译出来。所以这些应该是口头传统。有印度传统。还有可能来自美索不达米亚文化，追溯到巴比伦的传统。所以《阿拉伯之夜》的语料库，我认为它肯定是在巴格达开始汇编的。但一个女人为了不被杀而讲故事的想法来自
Persia. And lots of the constituent elements are meeting from all these different cultural traditions. It's a cocktail, Dominic. A cocktail. So basically, Tom, this is the literary embodiment of the thing that you've been saying throughout this series about the ideal of Baghdad being the crossroads of the world. Yes, absolutely. And that's why you will find in lots of the stories of the Arabian Nights mythologized versions of characters that we have been meeting throughout this episode. So Harun al-Rashid, who, as we said, he's a kind of fun guy. Yeah. The real Harun al-Rashid seems to have been very
波斯。许多组成元素来自所有这些不同的文化传统。这就像鸡尾酒，多米尼克。鸡尾酒。所以基本上，汤姆，这就是你在这整个系列中一直提到的关于巴格达作为世界十字路口的理想的文学体现。是的，绝对是。这就是为什么你在《阿拉伯之夜》的许多故事中会发现我们在本集节目中一直提到的那些人物的神话版本。比如哈伦·拉希德，正如我们所说，他是个有趣的人。是的。真实的哈伦·拉希德似乎非常
kind of pious and austere. So in the stories, he's always disguising himself and things. Yeah. He's kind of Bruce Wayne. He's going out from his great palace in disguise and cleaning up the streets and having all kinds of run-ins with everyday people. Jafar is there, the son of the physio. Oh, right. Yes. His friend. Haroun al-Rashid's great friend. There's a wonderful Borghesean story. Borghese, the great Argentinian short story writer, was obsessed by the Arabian Nights. This story, featuring Jafar, tells you why. This is a story called the Tale of Attaf. In it, Haroun visits a library in his palace. He takes a book out at random and he reads it and he laughs and he weeps. And at the end of it, Jafar is with him. He says to Jafar, you must go.
虔诚且朴素。所以在故事里，他总是乔装打扮之类的。是的。他有点像布鲁斯·韦恩。他从他伟大的宫殿里乔装走出来，清理街道，并与普通人发生各种各样的冲突。贾法尔也在那里，宰相的儿子。哦，对了。是的。哈伦·拉希德的好朋友。有一个精彩的博尔赫斯式的故事。博尔赫斯，那位伟大的阿根廷短篇小说家，对《阿拉伯之夜》着迷。这个以贾法尔为主角的故事告诉了你原因。这是一个名为《阿塔夫的故事》。在故事中，哈伦参观了他宫殿里的图书馆。他随机拿出一本书阅读，他笑了，也哭了。故事最后，贾法尔和他在一起。他对贾法尔说，你必须走。
And so Jafar is very upset by this. He doesn't know what's going on. What had Arun read in this book? And so he heads off. He ends up in Damascus. He meets a guy called Attaf. He gets embroiled in all kinds of adventures and shenanigans. And then he goes back to Baghdad and he reports back to Harun and Harun takes him into the library and pulls down the book and allows Jafar now to read it. And Jafar reads it. And in it, he finds the story of his own adventures with Attaf in Damascus. That is very Borghesean. Yeah. It's tremendous. And so there were lots of stories with these kind of twists. So Jafar is in it, so Bader is in it, all the kind of, you know, the jeweled slippers and the
所以贾法尔对此感到非常难过。他不知道发生了什么。哈伦在那本书里读到了什么？于是他出发了。他最终到了大马士革。他遇到了一个叫阿塔夫的人。他卷入了各种冒险和恶作剧。然后他回到巴格达，向哈伦汇报，哈伦带他走进图书馆，取下那本书，让贾法尔现在读它。贾法尔读了它。在书中，他发现了自己在大马士革与阿塔夫冒险的故事。那非常博尔赫斯。是的。太棒了。所以有很多带有这种转折的故事。贾法尔在里面，巴德尔在里面，所有那些，你知道，镶满珠宝的拖鞋和
wonderful spices and the poetry and all that kind of thing, and pavilions and, you know, all that kind of stuff. So that's all there. What about Sinbad, Tom? You said he's not in the Arabian Nights originally. No. So he's a corpus of stories that definitely goes back to the Abbasid period. You do get kind of echoes of the Odyssey. So there's a kind of a giant who throws a stone at Sinbad's ship, which clearly is an echo of Polyphemus. But I think the main inspiration for these stories is the fact that Muslim sailors are going from Basra down the Persian Gulf out into the Indian Ocean and perhaps even beyond and experiencing all kinds of extraordinary things. So one of the things, you mentioned the rock, didn't you? Oh, yes.
美妙的香料、诗歌等等，还有凉亭，你知道，所有那些东西。所以这些都在里面。那辛巴达呢，汤姆？你说他最初不在《阿拉伯之夜》里。是的。所以他是一个肯定可以追溯到阿拔斯王朝时期的故事集。你确实能得到某种《奥德赛》的回响。比如有一个巨人向辛巴达的船扔石头，这显然是波吕斐摩斯的呼应。但我认为这些故事的主要灵感来自于穆斯林水手从巴士拉出发，沿着波斯湾进入印度洋，甚至可能更远，并经历了各种非凡的事情。所以其中一件事，你提到了大鹏鸟，对吧？哦，是的。
In the opening, the rock is the giant bird, lays an enormous egg and its wings put entire islands in their shadow. And where does this story come from? There are some who say, well, it comes from traditions of giant birds in Indian culture. I mean, that's one answer. But another theory, which is the one that I always loved when I was a child and obsessively reading about this, is that it's a sailor's garbled account of a giant bird on Madagascar known as the elephant bird that had gone extinct by the 16th century, but would definitely have been seen by sailors from Basra in the Abbasid period. So I like to think that that's the origin of the story.
在开头，大鹏鸟是一种巨大的鸟，产下巨大的蛋，它的翅膀将整个岛屿笼罩在阴影中。这个故事来自哪里？有些人说，嗯，它来自印度文化中关于巨鸟的传统。我的意思是，这是一个答案。但另一个理论，也就是我小时候痴迷于阅读这些内容时一直喜欢的理论，是它是水手对马达加斯加一种被称为象鸟的巨鸟的模糊描述，这种鸟在16世纪就已经灭绝了，但阿拔斯王朝时期的巴士拉水手肯定见过。所以我喜欢认为那是这个故事的起源。
But I think the thing that is, in a way, most fascinating about the Arabian Nights, if you're looking for the mirror that it might hold up to Abbasid Baghdad, is the accounts it gives of low life. Because really, the Arabian Nights are not high literature. They're not viewed as high literature, certainly by Arabs. And so a lot of these stories are clearly coming from the streets. It gives you a glimpse into the kind of the see-me-under-belly, Domino. Oh, nice. I love a seamy underbelly, Tom. So rather like the Romans, the Baghdadis have entire classes of people who are viewed with
但我认为《阿拉伯之夜》最令人着迷的地方，如果你在寻找它可能为阿拔斯王朝时期的巴格达所持有的镜子，那就是它对底层生活的描述。因为实际上，《阿拉伯之夜》并不是高雅文学。它们不被视为高雅文学，至少在阿拉伯人看来是这样。所以很多这些故事显然来自街头。它让你瞥见了那种肮脏的内幕，多米尼克。哦，不错。我喜欢肮脏的内幕，汤姆。所以就像罗马人一样，巴格达人有整整阶层的人被
the utmost hauteur by kind of poets and literateurs and who therefore very rarely feature in literature. So people who were looked down on in Baghdad included blacksmiths, butchers, conjurers, policemen, night watchmen, tanners, makers of women's shoes, dung collectors, well diggers, bath stokers, masseurs, pigeon racers, intriguingly. So there's still that kind of shadow hanging over pigeon racers and chess players, oddly. To be fair, I look down on all those people today. Well, then you would have fitted in tremendously well into golden age Baghdad. I think I would.
诗人和文人以极度的傲慢看待，因此他们很少出现在文学作品中。所以巴格达被看不起的人包括铁匠、屠夫、魔术师、警察、夜巡人、制革工、女鞋匠、粪便收集者、挖井人、澡堂烧火工、按摩师、赛鸽者，有趣的是。所以赛鸽者和棋手身上仍然笼罩着那种阴影，奇怪的是。公平地说，我今天也看不起所有这些人。好吧，那你当时会非常适合黄金时代的巴格达。我想我会的。
So these are all the kind of people who appear in Adventures in the Arabian Nights. But there's one cast in particular who regularly feature, and these are criminals. And again, this is kind of echoes of Sherlock Holmes' London, Gotham City, the sense of master criminals. And this is something that does seem to have been a feature of Abbasid life, a kind of mingled fear and respect for Napoleons of crime. So the most celebrated of them all was a master criminal called Al-Uqab the Eagle. The most famous story that was told about him was he had a bet with a doctor that he would be able to steal something from the doctor's house. And so the doctor obviously puts enormous numbers of guards, locks everything up. And Al-Ukhab, he drugs the guards.
所以这些都是出现在《阿拉伯之夜》冒险故事中的人。但有一个群体特别引人注目，那就是罪犯。同样，这有点像福尔摩斯的伦敦、哥谭市，那种犯罪大师的感觉。这似乎确实是阿拔斯王朝生活的一个特征，一种对犯罪天才的混合了恐惧和尊重的态度。所以其中最著名的是一个叫“鹰”阿尔-乌卡布的犯罪大师。关于他最著名的故事是他和一个医生打赌，说他能从医生的房子里偷走东西。所以医生显然安排了大量的守卫，锁好了一切。而阿尔-乌卡布，他给守卫下了药。
And then his masterstroke is that he disguises himself as Jesus, bursts into the house, announces that he's Jesus, hypnotizes the doctor and steals the doctor himself, which is a superb twist. That's an excellent twist. And there are other master criminals as well. So there was a guy called Mercury Alley, and there was a female, I suppose she'd be a mistress criminal, wouldn't she? Who was called Crafty Delilah, who was hailed by Al-Masoudi as being the most famous confidence trickster in Baghdad. So this is the kind of the real life stuff that is providing material for the stories in the Arabian Nights. And there are definitely kind of stories that are being told about entire classes
然后他的绝招是他乔装成耶稣，闯进房子，宣布自己是耶稣，催眠了医生并偷走了医生本人，这是一个极好的转折。那是一个极好的转折。还有其他的犯罪大师。有一个叫“水银巷”的人，还有一个女性，我想她应该是一位犯罪女主人，对吧？她叫“狡猾的黛利拉”，被马苏第誉为巴格达最著名的诈骗犯。所以这就是为《阿拉伯之夜》的故事提供素材的现实生活中的东西。而且肯定有一些关于整个阶层的故事
of criminals in a tone of kind of grudging respect. We're told that there are corpuses of stranglers, bodies of stranglers who are going around, and they take dogs with them. Whenever they strangle someone, they'll beat the dog so that the dog's howling will drown out the cries of the guy who's being strangled, which is very sensible. But the best one is the burglars. Burglars never go anywhere in Baghdad without a tortoise. And they'll arrive at the house they want to burgle. They'll put the tortoise down. They get a candle out. They'll light the candle, put the candle on the tortoise's back and then push the tortoise through the front door. And the tortoise will wander in. And one of two things will happen. Either someone in the
罪犯的故事是以一种勉强尊重的语气讲述的。我们被告知有绞杀者群体，成群结队的绞杀者四处游荡，他们带着狗。每当他们勒死某人时，他们就会打狗，这样狗的嚎叫声就会淹没被勒死者的哭喊声，这非常明智。但最好的是小偷。小偷在巴格达从不带着乌龟去任何地方。他们会到达他们想偷窃的房子。他们会放下乌龟。他们拿出一支蜡烛。他们点燃蜡烛，把蜡烛放在乌龟背上，然后把乌龟推过前门。乌龟会走进去。然后会发生两件事中的一件。
house will go, blimey, there's a tortoise with a candle on its back, in which case they will know not to go in and burgle it. Or the tortoise will wander in, the candle will reveal that the house is empty and that there's lots of things to nick, and the burglars will pile in and they'll loot everything. So I think that this is very much the kind of background to, say, an oral story like Ali Baba and the 40 Thieves. Because in a way, Ali Baba is a thief. This is the story. He sees the Forty Thieves. They say, open sesame, the gate of the cave opens, it's full of gold. Ali Baba, in the long run, is able to purloin all this gold and finish off the Forty Thieves. And he does it thanks to the brilliant intelligence of his slave girl,
房子里的人会说：“天哪，有一只背着蜡烛的乌龟”，在这种情况下，他们就会知道不要进去偷窃。或者乌龟走进去，蜡烛照亮了房子，发现房子是空的，有很多东西可以偷，小偷就会蜂拥而入，洗劫一切。所以我认为这在很大程度上是像《阿里巴巴与四十大盗》这样的口头故事的背景。因为在某种程度上，阿里巴巴是个小偷。这就是故事。他看到了四十大盗。他们说“芝麻开门”，洞穴的门打开了，里面装满了黄金。阿里巴巴从长远来看，能够窃取所有这些黄金并干掉四十大盗。他之所以能做到这一点，多亏了他女奴的绝顶聪明，
Mulyana. And she was always my kind of favorite character in the Arabian Nights. And the wonderful thing about the Arabian Nights and its relationship to Abbasid Baghdad is that you can see that there were characters like this, there were people like this, that cunning was prized. And even though obviously the stories themselves aren't true, they do, I think, derive from an authentic tradition. And it's a tradition that kind of brings Baghdad more alive than perhaps contemplating mosques or, I don't know, Islamic scholarship. medieval cities. So this is our best window, probably, into that world, into the imaginations of the people who live there. Yeah. Fascinating.
穆利亚娜。她一直是我在《阿拉伯之夜》中最喜欢的角色。关于《阿拉伯之夜》及其与阿拔斯王朝巴格达的关系，美妙之处在于你可以看到确实有这样的角色，确实有这样的人，狡猾受到推崇。尽管故事本身显然不是真的，但我认为它们确实源于一种真实的传统。这是一种让巴格达比沉思清真寺或伊斯兰学术更生动的传统。中世纪城市。所以这可能是我们了解那个世界、了解生活在那里的人们想象力的最佳窗口。是的。太迷人了。
So your favourite character is Ali Baba's... Slave girl. Yes. Is that your favourite story, Ali Baba? So she's the one who is, you know,
所以你最喜欢的角色是阿里巴巴的……女奴。是的。那是你最喜欢的故事吗，阿里巴巴？所以她是那个，你知道，
the 40 thieves are in kind of jars and she pours boiling oil over them and everything and it's all great fun. So that's your favourite story? Yeah, I think it is. Okay.
四十大盗在罐子里，她把滚烫的油倒在他们身上，一切都很有趣。所以那是你最喜欢的故事？是的，我想是的。好吧。
Yeah. I always liked Sinbad because, of course, my pantomime career. Of course. They're all great stories. I should read them more, actually. I think Aladdin is okay yeah i always liked simbad because of course my pantomime career of course they're all great stories i should read them more actually you've really i think aladdin is actually a pretty bad story is it yeah i think so don't you i mean he's very passive just doing stuff with his genie in the lamp he's just kind of hanging out magic carpet i mean genies are great as well so they they are kind of creatures made of fire who uh you know have their own courts and everything and they're always appearing in the Arabian Nights.
是的。我一直喜欢辛巴达，因为，当然，我的哑剧生涯。当然。它们都是伟大的故事。我其实应该多读读它们。我觉得阿拉丁还可以，是的，我一直喜欢辛巴达，因为当然，我的哑剧生涯，当然，它们都是伟大的故事，我其实应该多读读它们，你真的，我认为阿拉丁其实是一个很糟糕的故事，是吗？是的，我想是这样，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，他非常被动，只是用他的神灯精灵做些事情，他只是在闲逛，魔毯，我的意思是精灵也很棒，所以他们是那种由火制成的生物，呃，你知道，有他们自己的宫廷等等，他们总是出现在《阿拉伯之夜》中。
So all great stuff. And so resonant of the romance of this world that you've been bringing alive for us so brilliantly. Tom, dare I say a tour de force? Yeah, thank you. I think I will. Thank you very much. So that was tremendous.
所以一切都很棒。而且非常能引起你一直为我们生动呈现的这个世界浪漫色彩的共鸣。汤姆，我敢说这是一部杰作吗？是的，谢谢。我想我会的。非常感谢。所以那太棒了。
That's medieval Baghdad. Now, next week, we are sailing the high seas in the company of Yorkshire's finest Captain Cook. And we will be landing on Australia and New Zealand and interfering with the locals like Captain Cook. We will be doing, of course, later this autumn. So that will be very exciting. But Tom, thank you very much. That was absolutely brilliant.
那是中世纪的巴格达。现在，下周，我们将陪伴约克郡最优秀的库克船长航行公海。我们将登陆澳大利亚和新西兰，像库克船长一样干预当地人。我们当然会在今年秋天晚些时候这样做。所以那会非常令人兴奋。但汤姆，非常感谢。那绝对太棒了。
And thank you to all of you for listening. And we will hopefully see you next week. Goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
也感谢大家的收听。我们希望下周能见到你们。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。